[Musique]
port est devenu
plus de grandes sagas internationale
nous découvrons les concepteurs en plein
travail
non je pense que nadine maintenant elle
est allée au point où elle doit
complètement changé de look nous ce
feuilleton est en train de se casser la
gueule aux moments importants où on va
américanisé nadine il se casse la gueule
on va l'envoyer en espagne là bas j'ai
perdu ce que nos escales cela que
ridicule ridicule
il ya eu des personnages comme nul ne
peut pas tomber amoureuse un personnage
comme lui un appareil impossible mais
par contre le ps 14 h 30 pétanque
personnage bestial on était prêt à la la
justement vous a suffi un tiens j'en
vois un autre là tu te souviens d'akbar
[Musique]
l'amour tout ils ont des vues un peu un
peu ambigu nom d'aimia le double ici
avait un truc entre petit robert et
mojito ça donnerait un truc un peu sec
ce made in c'est une fille gentille
nadine est même pas sex à l'alhambra cjt
mens je vais en boîte mais elle embrasse
elle embrasse elle embrasse quel joli
crap je le fais un bisou
quel jeu
faire un bisou qu'elle j'avais burricand
je vais faire un bisou jolie maggie
lawson
quel joli berger allemand j'ai été
ambitieux qu'elle se libère le chanteur
je vais rouler une pelle
je fais un bisou quand j'allume
arbitrage l'univers hobbies m'envoyer
vos jambes sur la bouche et barbie
écouter écouter arrêtez s'il vous plaît
arrêtez pluie qui vous êtes de bons
c'est monsieur berlusconi qui m'envoient
parce que vous comprenez avec oui mais
c'est le directeur qui vont voir avec le
sport et il fallait le dire plutôt une
bonne idée derrière sympathique
[Musique]